Her son would be avenged.
Whispers slithered through the taverns and
back alleys of Flea Bottom.
Two men were found; one was a former gold
cloak, the other a rat catcher in the Red
Keep who knew all its secrets.
History remembers them only as Blood and Cheese.
One night, Queen Helaena entered the royal
apartments with her daughter and two sons
to put them to bed.
Without warning, Blood and Cheese burst in,
daggers in hand.
They told her that a debt was owed.
A son for a son.
Blood and Cheese demanded she choose which
son would be ripped from her forever.
Queen Helaena pleaded with the men to kill
her instead, but they refused.
Weeping, Helaena named her younger son Maelor.
Perhaps she thought the boy was too young
to understand, perhaps because the older boy
was King Aegon's firstborn son and heir.
"You hear that, little boy?"
Cheese whispered to the younger son.
"Your mama wants you dead."
Then Blood struck off the older boy's head
with a single blow.
When the guards burst in, they found Queen
Helaena still screaming, clasping her dead
son's body to her, mad with grief.
The blood of her children transformed a dynastic
dispute into a war
of annihilation.
The grief and rage of losing a child could
burn down the world.
Either Aegon or Rhaenyra could live at the
end, but not both.
Viserys: Rhaenyra's forces struck yet another
blow.
The moment the Lord of Harrenhal saw Daemon
Targaryen circling the castle on his dragon
Caraxes, he struck his banners and surrendered.
The Blacks now had the strongest castle in
the Riverlands.
Darker news still came to Aegon; thanks to
Rhaenyra's sons, Winterfell had declared for
Rhaenyra, as had the Vale.
Furious, Aegon dismissed his grandfather,
Ser Otto, as Hand and appointed Ser Criston
Cole, who swore to march on all the lords
who had declared for Rhaenyra and put their
castles to the torch.
Cole and the royal army first marched north
and laid siege to Rook's Rest, a Black stronghold
near Dragonstone.
When the Lord saw their approach, he sent
a raven to Rhaenyra begging for help.
For days he watched his fields and villages
burning, with no response from his queen.
Until one day, a shadow passed over the Green
army.
Rhaenyra had sent not an army, but her former
mother-by-law Rhaenys and her dragon Meleys.
As her ancestor had done at the Field of Fire,
Rhaenys gleefully began to incinerate Ser
Criston's army.
But Aegon had set a trap, and Rhaenys had
flown right into it.
As Rhaenys and Meleys blanketed Ser Criston's
troops in dragonflame, two other dragons rose
into the sky.
Aemond on Vhagar and King Aegon himself on
the gleaming Sunfyre.
To her credit, Rhaenys didn't flee.
Dragon fought dragons, and a second sun blossomed
in the sky.
When the smoke cleared, only Aemond and Vhagar
stood uninjured.
Sunfyre, the most magnificent dragon in the
world, had one of its wings almost completely
torn from its body.
Trapped beneath Sunfyre was the king himself,
broken and burned so badly in places that
his armor had fused onto his flesh.
His body survived, but his mind was given
over to milk of the poppy.
Meleys had been torn to shreds, and her rider,
Rhaenys, was a pile of ash.
Panicked by the defeat, Rhaenyra shipped her
two youngest sons across the Narrow Sea for
their protection.
Only for her youngest to return days later,
clinging to the neck of his wounded and dying
dragon.
He and his brother had been set upon by an
enemy fleet just off Dragonstone.
Defying his mother's command, Rhaenyra's eldest
son and heir, Jacaerys, mounted his dragon
Vermaxand flew to rescue his other brother
and punish the enemy fleet.
But the foolish boy let Vermax be hooked like
a trout and dragged into the sea, where he
soaked up even more arrows than seawater.
His brother disappeared over the horizon or
beneath the waves.
No one could say for sure.
With the loss of four dragons, Rhaenyra's
only advantage was fading.
Luckily for her, over the centuries, House
Targaryen had spilled more than blood on Dragonstone.
She promised gold and title to any of the
Targaryen bastards who could tame the six
untamed dragons on the island.
These bastards were called the dragonseeds,
though most were called supper.
Perhaps the dragons were eventually sated
or bored, but four of them accepted riders
and were enlisted in Rhaenyra's cause.
Robert: After Rook's Rest, Aemond One-Eye
took command of the Greens from his crippled
and poppy-addled brother.
Aemond was the blood of the dragon, and dragons
don't cower behind city walls.
He marched the king's army north to take back
Harrenhal from Rhaenyra's husband, Daemon.
But when he and Criston Cole reached the castle,
they found the gates open, with Daemon and
all his men gone.
That night they feasted their victory; Daemon
had fled rather than face their wrath.
But Daemon was more snake than dragon.
As Aemond marched north, he'd flown Caraxes
south, slithering past the Green army over
the waters of the Gods Eye.
One day King's Landing looked up and saw two
dragons circling their foul city.
Daemon and Rhaenyra had come for her throne,
for the city was defenseless.
Aemond had taken the king's army from the
city, and worse, he'd taken his dragon Vhagar.
Seeing that resistance was hopeless, the small
council surrendered the city, the Queen Mother
Alicent, and the broken Queen Helaena.
But not King Aegon.
Somehow, despite his wounds and delirium,
he had vanished from the city.
And so Queen Rhaenyra climbed the steps and
seated herself of the Iron Throne.
Legend has it that as she left that hall later,
blood trickled down her legs and hands, proving
the Iron Throne had spurned her.
Nonsense!
It's a chair made of steel blades.
Rhaenyra had wanted it all her life and had
sacrificed two sons for it.
She likely gripped the damn thing too tight.
Viserys: When Aemond realized that his arrogance
had cost him the capital, he mounted Vhagar
in a black rage and rained fire onto every
village and castle he suspected of disloyalty.
Abandoned by Aemond, Ser Criston marched the
royal army back to King's Landing, intent
on recapturing the city himself.
Instead, he was trapped and cut to pieces
by the Riverlords, who had sworn to support
Rhaenyra's claim.
When a new army of Green loyalists marched
up from the Reach and laid siege to the city
of Tumbleton, Rhaenyra sent two of her dragonseeds
to lay waste to them.
Instead, the dragonseeds proved their bastard
nature and betrayed her.
They burned the city and all the Black forces
garrisoned within.
Lucky for her, they didn't turn towards King's
Landing but whored and drank in the ruins
with the Greens, who were victorious and somewhat
confused.
Oberyn Martell: Rhaenyra now mistrusted all
the dragonseeds, including the girl who rode
with her husband Daemon, hunting Aemond in
the Riverlands.
She ordered the girl's head be sent to her.
But there was a complication.
As well as her dragon, the girl had taken
to riding Daemon.
When Daemon received the queen's order, he
proclaimed it a queen's words and a whore's
work.
He sent the girl away at dawn, watching her
and her dragon vanish into the morning mists.
Then Daemon sent a challenge to his nephew
Aemond and flew to Harrenhal alone to wait.
Fourteen days later, a shadow blacker than
any passing cloud swept over Harrenhal.
Vhagar had come at last and on her rode one-eyed
Prince Aemond.
He mocked Daemon for facing him alone.
"You have lived too long, uncle."
And Daemon replied, "On that much, we agree."
Then the old prince climbed stiffly onto the
back of his dragon Caraxes but neglected to
fasten the chains that secured rider to saddle.
The sun was close to setting when, as one,
the two dragons leapt into the sky.
Daemon took Caraxes up swiftly until he disappeared
into a bank of clouds.
Vhagar, older and slower, ascended more gradually.
Up and up, Vhagar soared, searching for Caraxes.
Sudden as a thunderbolt, a shrieking Caraxes
dove upon Vhagar.
Locked together, the dragons tumbled toward
the lake.
Caraxes' jaws closed upon Vhagar's neck, but
Vhagar ripped open Caraxes's belly, and her
teeth ripped off a wing.
The lake rushed up with terrible speed.
Then Daemon Targaryen, who had never fastened
his riding chains, stood in his saddle.
He leapt from his dragon to Aemond's, and
in his hand was Dark Sister, the Valyrian
sword of Aegon's sister-queen Visenya.
As Aemond One-Eye looked up in terror, Daemon
ripped off his nephew's helm and drove the
sword down into his one remaining eye so hard
the point came out the back of the young prince's
throat.
Half a heartbeat later, the dragons struck
the lake, sending up a gout of water so high
that it was said to have been as tall as Harrenhal's
great tower.
The lake boiled with dragon blood and then
was still.
Daemon Targaryen was nine-and-forty at his
death.
Prince Aemond had only turned twenty.
Vhagar, the greatest of the Targaryen dragons,
had counted one-hundred-and-eighty-one years.
Thus passed the last living creature from
the days of Aegon's Conquest.
Viserys: Back in King's Landing, Queen Rhaenyra
didn't have much time to grieve for her stupid
husband.
The mad former queen Helaena flung herself
from a balcony, to be impaled upon the iron
spikes lining the moat of Maegor's Holdfast.
That night, the city rose in riot against
Rhaenyra, demanding justice for Queen Helaena
and her murdered son, among other foolish
peasantfantasies.
In the midst of this chaos, a one-handed fool
called the Shepherd began to rant against
dragons.
Not just the ones of the enemy, but all dragons
everywhere.
As he pointed to the Dragonpit above on the
hill, he shouted, "There the demons dwell,
this is their city.
If you would make it yours, first you must
destroy them."
A cry went up from ten thousand throats, "Kill
them!"
There were four dragons housed within the
Dragonpit that night.
By the time the first of the attackers came
pouring in, all four were roused, awake and
angry.
Nobody knows how many men and women died that
night.
Who cares?
They all should have!
Trapped within the pit, the dragons could
not fly.
Instead, they fought with horns, claws, teeth,
and fire.
For every man who died, ten more appeared,
shouting that the dragons must die.
One by one, they did.
Finally, the last remaining dragon broke her
chain, spread her wings, and flew straight
up at the great dome trying to flee.
Already weakened by dragonflame, the dome
cracked under the force of impact and then
tumbled down, crushing the dragonslayers and
herself.
Joffrey Baratheon: High atop the Red Keep,
Queen Rhaenyra clutched her two remaining
sons to her as she watched the end of her
family's might, too afraid of the peasants
to defend her dragons.
At least her older son, Joffrey, had a man's
spine.
He stole his mother's dragon Syrax and tried
to fly it to the Dragonpit to save his birthright.
But the stupid beast didn't understand and
twisted beneath him, fighting to be free of
the little boy, until it was.
A queen is still a woman, with all the weakness
of that sex.
Weeping for her lost son more than her dragons,
Rhaenyra abandoned the Iron Throne and sold
her crown to buy passage for her and her last
son back to Dragonstone.
Rhaenyra hoped to hatch more dragons from
the eggs in the castle.
But when she landed, the welcoming party slew
her guards and marched her and her son at
spearpoint to the castle to face a dead man
and a dying dragon.
"Sister!"
King Aegon, Second of His Name, called out
to Rhaenyra.
Rook's Rest had left Aegon bent and twisted,
his once handsome face puffy from milk of
the poppy, with burn scars covering half his
body.
Rhaenyra, ever defiant, told her dear brother
that she'd hoped he was dead.
"After you!"
Aegon answered.
Then Sunfyre bathed her in a blast of flame
and devoured her in six bites while her son
watched, leaving the seventh and final bite,
her lower leg, for the Stranger.
Viserys: Rhaenyra was dead, and King Aegon
sat the Iron Throne again.
But only for half a year.
He was poisoned by his own men and replaced
with the very boy who had watched his mother
devoured.
Shireen: When Rhaenyra's last son wed Aegon's
only daughter, the Dance of Dragons officially
ended.
Ash and burned men.
All that was left of the Riverlands.
Two scared children spouting oaths they didn't
understand.
All that was left of the mighty House Targaryen.
Ancient skulls and hatchlings that grew no
bigger than cats.
All that was left of the dragons.